[Music]
how do we know who we are how do we know
where we exist in our brain our identity
something that everybody knows but can't
define
I spent much of my day trying to answer
these very what used to be philosophical
questions which are now biological
questions I am a cognitive
neuroscientist and I study the brain and
all aspects of self-awareness deception
and how people think about themselves
our expert cognitive neuroscientist
explores identity and the mind with the
help of the new Hulu original series
chants in our initial studies we showed
subjects to their own face and what we
discovered is that when you look at
yourself either in a picture or in the
mirror the neurons in the right
prefrontal cortex get very very excited
and they start firing what we call
action potentials when you remove that
right hemisphere or temporarily
disrupted people have a very difficult
time thinking about themselves or
reacting to their own face we know that
anywhere in that frontal cortex damage
to those areas can cause a very profound
personality change Jacquelyn Blackstone
he struck you in the face with the jack
handle shortly thereafter and you became
aware of a second personality Jackie
black
those things that I didn't want to do I
would best describe it neuroscientists
talking about dissociative identity
disorder as skeptical we do know that
it's an often faked disorder on the
other hand someone who suffers
post-traumatic stress disorder often has
a related dissociative identity disorder
with them the person goes back to the
traumatic event one of the findings and
neuroscience is that whether you're
faking it or it's actually real your
brain doesn't really know the difference
people who are feigning di D can
actually fool the scanner into believing
that these are two different personality
states the self is very fluid and it
shifts from situation to situation it's
very malleable and it's very adaptable
you haven't been yourself for a long
time one of the discoveries in our lab
is how much people don't know about
themselves who they are what they've
done who they're going to become people
are very inaccurate when they evaluate
themselves ingrained in every human
being is some level of self-deception
why that is is that it's actually pretty
healthy to not know who you are that the
people who know who they are tend to
suffer from clinical depression
look after yourself Elton
having yourself is maybe the most
precious gift given to every human being
that we can actually think about who we
are and I think that's what makes us
human
you
[Music]